at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking discover this podcast is brought
to you by the ready state virtual
mobility coach what on earth is that
well let me back up the first person I
personally call for help with my
athletic recovery or mobility training
is dr. Kelly Starrett at the ready state
I've known Kelly for more than a decade
I was introduced to him for a bunch of
reasons I've seen him perform near
miracles on me and many others he's a
good friend but he's also mobility and
movement coach for Olympic gold medalist
world champions and pro athletes you
might recognize the name because Kelly
was in the 4-hour body he was in tools
of titans he's been on this podcast
he also nursed and coached me through
the destroy my body for entertainment TV
show that was the Tim Ferriss experiment
and I made it through those 13 episodes
because of Kelly would not have survived
now Kelly has created a program called
virtual mobility coach it's like
carrying a virtual Kelly Starrett
in your pocket because most people are
not gonna have direct access to Kelly
but now you do every day
virtual mobility coach gives you guided
mobility videos walks you step-by-step
through Kelly's proven techniques to
relieve pain improve range of motion
improve performance on and on and on and
on there are a lot of things you can do
with this program and you've got to
check it out it's encyclopedic but
simultaneously really easy to navigate
if you're in pain you can pull up a
picture of the human body click on what
hurts and from there
get customized regimen to help find
relief if you are working out or playing
a sport virtual mobility coach offers
all sorts of pre and post exercise
mobility sequences for more than 50
sports and activities actually so those
will help you warm up before your
workouts so you can run faster jump
higher lift heavier all with a lower
risk of injury and if you're not in pain
or working out virtual mobility coach
also has a library of
maintenance videos great way to speed up
recovery in your off days which also
helps a lot with sleep much of that
stuff and right now listeners of this
podcast get a special deal you can try
virtual mobility coach you can get the
Kelly Starrett in your pocket totally
risk-free for two weeks without paying a
penny it is a two week free trial so you
should try it out Kelly is super legit
he is literally the person I text and
call with the most sophisticated /
esoteric questions about recovery and
injuries I've inflicted upon myself he
knows what he's doing and his stuff
really really works so try it for free
for two weeks and then after that if you
decide to continue you can get 50% off
your first six months the readystate
dot-com / Tim and use code Tim 50 at
checkout so again that's the ready state
calm / Tim and use code Tim 50 at
checkout hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is usually my job to sit down
with world-class performers of all
different types startup founders
investors chess champions Olympic
athletes you name it to tease out that
habits that you can apply in your own
lives this episode however is an
experiment and part of a short-form
series that I'm doing simply called
books I've loved I've invited some
amazing past guests close friends and
new faces to share their favorite books
describe their favorite books the books
that have influenced them changed them
transform them for the better and I hope
you pick up one or two new mentors in
the form of books from this new series
and apply the lessons in your own life I
had a lot of fun putting this together
inviting these people to participate and
have learned so so much myself I hope
that is also the case for you please
enjoy
so to kick things off here are four of
my personal recommendations which I had
originally included in the back of the
4-hour workweek when it was published in
2007 back when I had hair I called these
four books the fundamental four and I
still do recommend them to a lot of
people they are so named the fundamental
four because they were the four books I
recommended to aspiring lifestyle
designers and entrepreneurs prior to
writing the 4-hour workweek that was a
long time ago they are still very well
worth reading and here's the sequence
that I suggest very specifically the
first is the magic of thinking big by
David Schwartz this book was first
recommended to be by Stephen key an
ultra successful inventor who has made
millions of dollars licensing products
to companies like Disney Nestle
coca-cola the list is very very long it
is the favorite book of many super
performers worldwide I've spoken with
ranging from legendary football coaches
to famous CEOs many of my podcast guests
have also brought this up and it has
more than 100 five-star ratings on
Amazon the main message is pretty simple
don't overestimate others and
underestimate yourself I still
personally read the first two chapters
of this book
whenever doubt creeps in note that it is
a little dated it is outdated in some
respects in terms of tone so you just
have to accept that as part of the
package but nonetheless I find it to be
a very helpful philosophical and
psychological reboot because in my
experience especially in the last say 12
months I've realized that it's not just
enough to automate and streamline and
I've noticed in the last handful of
months stress creeping in in the form of
having to fix a lot of things and
feeling strained for time to create much
of anything and the solution is not just
removing the niggly minutia that are
bothering you you need a compelling big
goal you need an inspiring abnormally
large
objective to chase and this book really
helps with that type of reorientation
the next book is how to make millions
with your ideas subtitle and
entrepreneurs guide that is by Dan s
Kennedy this book is also dated to keep
in mind these recommendations are
originally from 2007 but it still does
the job this is a menu of options for
converting ideas into millions of
dollars I read this first when I was in
high school and have read it many times
since let's call it six to twelve it is
like steroids for your entrepreneurial
cortex the case studies range from
Domino's Pizza to casinos to Miller
products really lay out a spectrum of
options and that's kind of the point
if you think of business and in
quotation marks business represents in
your mind a very specific one type of
business model a path that is codified
maybe calcified like venture-backed
startups and you go from your seed round
or your convertible debt to your this to
your that if you only have one script
that is associated with business in your
mind this will help to stretch you it is
very very effective for that I would
also suggest combining and I'm cheating
a little bit here and adding an extra
book but there is a book by Steven K so
this is the amazing inventor who
initially recommended the magic of
thinking it big to me there's a book he
wrote called one simple idea and that is
the main title one simple idea subtitle
turn your dreams into a licensing
goldmine while letting others to the
work so it's a compelling title it's an
excellent book about licensing so
instead of venturing instead of doing
the manufacturing yourself instead of
handling a lot of the nuts and bolts and
operations how can you if you are good
at inventing license products and I know
readers who have read the 4-hour
workweek one specific person to mine
Steve hey Steve you're gonna recognize
this this but I know permission to tell
us a full story who read the 4-hour
workweek then read one simple idea and
he's now making up to eighty five
thousand dollars a day with some of his
products and that's certainly on the
high end of outcomes but it's not
completely impossible
and there are many other successes the
next book I wanna mention so the third
book of the fundamental for is the
e-myth revisited subtitle why most small
businesses don't work and what to do
about it this is by Michael Gerber this
is a classic Gerber is a masterful
storyteller and this classic of
automation discusses how to use a
franchise mindset not necessarily the
business model but a franchise mindset
to create scalable businesses that are
based on rules and systems and not
outstanding employees I've certainly
felt the pain of making the mistake of
trying to focus on hiring Michael Jones
as opposed to having sufficient systems
in place and this can be very very
beneficial this book either when you're
first thinking of starting your first
business or as another reboot if you've
strayed from the path of systems and
rules and process this provides an
excellent roadmap told in parable for
becoming an owner instead of a constant
micro manager and for those of you who
have a lot of time in the trenches you
will probably recognize that it is easy
to fall into the trap of micromanaging
or just looking for the superstar
employees who are going to be completely
self driven without any guidance to
solve your problems and there are
aspects of that we could discuss in a
separate forum but suffice to say if
you're stuck in your own business this
book can help you get unstuck
that's the e-myth revisited the next one
is and this is the fourth of the
fundamental four is vagabonding an
uncommon guide to the art of long term
world travel by Rolf Potts
Rolf Potts is the man he's great he's
become a friend I read this book a long
long time ago this is in fact the book
that got me to stop making excuses
impact for an extended hiatus trip
overseas
it covers bits of everything and don't
discount it because the subtitle has
long term world travel in it maybe
that's not what you want to do but it
covers a lot it's helpful for
determining your destination or
destinations if you're thinking about
travel adjusting to life on the road and
reassimilated back into ordinary life
but it also includes great excerpts from
famous vagabonds philosophers and
explorers as well as anecdotes from
ordinary travelers
this is really a philosophical reset
this book helps you to better value time
wealth while recognizing the limitations
of money as currency in the end which
most people want to trade for an
experience which gives them an emotion
so it really helps to deconstruct your
own thinking about materialism success
as quantified by money and the trappings
that we all fall into the trappings that
we all succumb to at various points it
happens and this book is one that I've
read at least 10 times I still have my
original copy this is the first of two
books the other was Walden that I took
with me on my first 15 month mini
retirement around the world that was
from 2004 onward where all the tango
stuff and all the craziness happened in
my life and it really did change my life
so vagabonding is the fourth book of the
fundamental four and the sequence again
that I recommend not mandatory but that
I would recommend is the magic thinking
big number one how to make millions with
your ideas by Dan Kennedy and/or Stephen
Keyes one simple idea then you have the
e-myth revisited by Michael Gerber and
then vagabonding but certainly you can
pick and choose and grab one of those
out of order vagabonding also I noticed
after many years had no audio book so I
produced that audio book myself and
released it you can find that in my
audio book club on audible if you just
go to audible.com forward slash Tim's
books you can find that I'm going to
give you guys one bonus book and I know
I'm cheating but the bonus book is
awareness subtitle the perils and
opportunities of reality by Anthony de
Mello so the book awareness subtitled
the perils and opportunities of reality
by Anthony de Mello this short book has
completely captured me and just in the
last two years I've probably reread it
five or six times and when I feel myself
bleeding into overwhelm or feeling
scattered this is one of the first
break glass in case of emergency steps
that I take I pick it up and I read a
few chapters it was first recommended to
me by Peter Mallick who is associated
with wealth management investing in
finance he was on the podcast because he
said that it gave him peace of mind for
weeks at a time and it was a bit of a
non sequitur in our conversation and I
took a note about it I grabbed the
Kindle version with very low
expectations because come on the title
sounds super generic in some respects
awareness okay there are a million in
one books that claim to be about
awareness what the hell does that mean
anyway the subtitle is more interesting
the perils and opportunities of reality
so I grabbed it with low expectations
devoured it in three days
and I have bought dozens of copies to
give to friends I mean 20 30 40 50 to
give it to friends I have an entire
shelf in the guest bedroom in my house
that is it's full of copies of this book
for guests to take with them when they
leave it found me at the right time and
it won't resonate with everyone but it
has equally impacted several of my close
friends and buddies I've recommended
this too so it's worth checking out
awareness by Anthony de Mello those are
you want to count at 4 or 5 4 5 6 books
and I'm gonna leave it at that for now
thank you for listening and I hope you
check out one of those books and find
any of them even partially as valuable
as I did and if you find that they will
be worth the time
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include a favorite articles
that I have read and that I've shared
with my close friends for instance and
it's very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that check it out just go to 4-hour
workweek come that's 4-hour workweek
calm all spelled out and just drop in a
few old email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoy it this podcast is brought to you
by the readystate virtual mobility coach
what on earth is that well a new backup
the first person I personally call for
help with my athletic recovery or
mobility training is dr. Kelly Starrett
at the ready state
I've known Kelly for more than a decade
I was introduced to him for a bunch of
reasons I've seen him perform near
miracles on me he and many others he's a
good friend but he's also mobility and
movement coach for Olympic gold medalist
world champions and pro athletes you
might recognize the name because Kelly
was in the 4-hour body he was in choice
of titans he's been on this podcast
he also nursed and coached me through
the destroy my body for entertainment TV
show that was the Tim Ferriss experiment
and I made it through those 13 episodes
because of Kelly would not have survived
now Kelly has created a program called
virtual mobility coach it's like
carrying a virtual Kelly Starrett in
your pocket because most people are not
going to have direct access to Kelly but
now you do every day
virtual mobility coach gives you guided
mobility videos walks you step-by-step
through Kelly's proven techniques to
relieve pain and through range of motion
improve performance on and on and on
there are a lot of things you can do
with this program and you gotta check it
out it's encyclopedic but simultaneously
really easy to navigate if you're in
pain you can pull up a picture of your
body
click on what hurts and from there get
customized regimen to help finally if
you are working out of playing a sport
virtual mobility coach offers all sorts
of pre and post exercise mobility
sequences for more than 50 sports and
activities actually so those will help
you warm up before your workout so you
can run faster jump higher or lift
heavier all with a lower risk of injury
and if you're not in pain or working up
virtual mobility coach also has a
library of daily maintenance videos
great way to speed up recovery in your
off days which also helps a lot with
sleep a bunch of that stuff and right
now listeners of this podcast get
special deal you can try virtual
mobility coach you can get Kelly
Starrett in your pocket totally
risk-free for two weeks without paying a
penny it is a two week free trial so you
should try it out Kelly is super legit
he is literally the person I text and
call with the most sophisticated /
esoteric questions about recovery and
injuries I've inflicted upon myself he
knows what he's doing and his stuff
really really works to try it for free
for two weeks and then after that if you
decide to continue you can get 50% off
your first six months the readystate
comm / Tim use code Tim 50 at checkout
so again that's the ready state comm /
Tim and use code 1050 at checkout
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you
you